Speaker 1: All right, we're going to start
today looking at an interview billed as an
exclusive interview, if you can imagine that,
by right wing radical TV network Newsmax with
former President Donald Trump.
Donald Trump, of course, giving a completely
insane interview, lying about just about everything.
But this is the man still at the head of the
Republican Party.
This is the man who most Republicans still
say they would vote for.
say did win in November and they would follow
him out of the Republican Party to his own
third party, or so they say, or so they say.
Let's just get right into it.
We're not going to be able to look at all
of it, but let's at least start looking at
some of it.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, thank you for sitting
down with us.
This experiment of Joe Biden as president.
It's only been four months and in a short
four months, America's enduring numerous crises,
both abroad and at home.
It seems our country is deteriorating very
fast even.
I would have thought your reaction.
Great question.
Well, it's pretty obvious.
You look at what's going to happen is even
scarier.
The border is a disaster.
We had the strongest border we've ever had.
And within a month it became the weakest.
And now you have tens of thousands of people
flowing into our countries.
Speaker 1: And so already, OK, already understand
the number of lives there.
The border was a situation under Trump.
It's a situation under Biden.
It's gotten slightly better under Biden.
That's the situation.
There's a seasonality to crossings, which
we've already talked about.
But this is already a framing that's completely
absurd.
It's just this is fantasy world framing and
this is what the entire interview was.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: The criminals, frankly, released
from jails in numerous countries.
We have people coming in from the Middle East.
We have people coming in from everywhere you
go to the airport.
Speaker 1: So just casually, that's another
unproven, unproven statement that there are
people coming in through the border from the
Middle East.
He keeps repeating it.
They all keep repeating it, but there's not
actually evidence that that really took place.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: Go.
How are you doing?
You come through the southern border and you
just walk in with the strongest southern border
ever.
And it's very sad to see the wall was so important.
You know, we built almost five hundred miles
of wall.
Speaker 1: Remember that most of that was
just wall that was redone.
That's all.
That's all that was I think about 70 miles
of new wall were added, just another lie.
Speaker 2: And within a month it would have
been finished and they ended it.
Speaker 1: And of course, within a month,
nothing would have been finished.
He he promised that by the end of his first
term, there would be a wall across the entire
border.
One more month would not have done anything.
Speaker 2: They ended it took two and a half
years to get the approvals.
To do what?
I had to go to court.
I had to do everything.
We got the approvals.
And so you have open spots and it's ridiculous.
I hear they're going to close them up.
But now it's a big deal with the contractors
because those deals were those those transactions
were made.
It was all complete.
But you look at ramblings, it's very sad to
see what's happening.
Inflation is going to be a big problem.
Speaker 1: It's going to drive.
So free association.
Now on to a new topic.
Speaker 2: A lot of things up and down, whichever
is worse because bad.
Speaker 1: Did you guys catch that?
Inflation is going to drive things up and
down, whichever is worse.
Could be up.
Could be down either way.
It's definitely going to be very bad.
Speaker 2: Things happen with inflation, but
you see that happening all over lumber, the
cost of lumber, the cost of gasoline.
You look at gasoline.
What's happened now is at two eighty seven
was was high.
Speaker 1: Remember that gasoline prices started
climbing dramatically under Trump.
Presidents have very little to do with gas
prices, but they started climbing under Trump.
The reason was there was a complete collapse
in demand for gasoline at the start of the
pandemic.
At the end of twenty twenty, things started
going the opposite direction.
Gas prices were going up under Trump.
They've continued up under Biden because the
economy is opening and because there is now
demand.
Speaker 2: That's when I got involved and
it was in the threes and a little bit in the
fours.
And then I got came in and I had it under
two dollars added for a dollar eighty seven
actually.
And when I left it was under two dollars substantially.
And now it's, it's going to be hitting four
dollars, meaningless, bigger than any tax
increase you can think of, especially for
middle income people.
So a lot of it,
Speaker 1: by the way, that's also untrue.
If you look at just the average miles driven
by middle income people, gas at three seventy
versus gas at one ninety, it is a difference,
but it's it's not significant in the way Donald
Trump wants you to believe relative to so
many other things.
Child tax, credit, covid, cash, everything
is a lie.
Speaker 2: Things are happening.
I don't think we're respected in the world.
Speaker 1: That's again, another factual,
demonstrable lie I respect.
And approval of the United States has skyrocketed
since Trump left.
We have studies on this Pew Global Research.
We have we've looked at them, Drumlin.
Radically better opinion of the United States
around the world since Donald Trump left,
everything is a lie.
Speaker 2: My friends right now, they would
never moves on Taiwan by joining our bombers
flying over Taiwan.
Russia would have never encircled Ukraine
like they did.
Kim Jong un was somebody that I had a great
relationship with.
We weren't going to have any problem with
him, in my opinion.
And now you look at what's going on.
There are a lot of bad things are happening.
I want to ask about the Wuhan lab warning
this week from The Wall Street Journal about
workers there being so sickened as far back
as November of twenty nineteen that they were
hospitalized.
The corporate media now that we're
Speaker 1: going to talk about this later
today and tomorrow,
Speaker 2: bull by his corporate media is
starting to come around to recognize that
perhaps that is the origin, in fact, of the
China virus.
Even Dr. Foushee is changing his tune.
Do you feel vindicated?
And and again, his corporate media is starting
to come around to recognize
Speaker 1: Dr. Fauci is not changing his tune.
OK, Dr. Fauci has said all along investigate
things.
But right now we don't have evidence.
This was a manmade bioweapon.
Speaker 2: I have no doubt about it.
I had no doubt about it.
I was criticized by the press because China
has a lot of people taken care of.
They took care of Hunter, they took care of
Joe.
They took care of everybody, didn't they?
And people didn't want to say China.
Usually they blame it on Russia.
It's always Russia, Russia, Russia.
But I said right at the beginning, it came
out of one.
And that's where all the deaths were.
Also, by the way, when we first heard about
this
Speaker 1: now, of course, remember, it came
out of Wuhan is very different.
Nobody denies that that was the human centered
infection source.
The question is, was it an engineered bioweapon,
as they claim?
Was it naturally occurring studying in a lab
and it accidentally leaked?
I have no problem investigating those things,
as I've said from the beginning.
But Donald Trump says, I know exactly what
it was.
How does he know?
He doesn't know anything about this stuff.
Speaker 2: There were body bags, dead people
laying all over Wuhan Province, and that's
where it happened to be located.
So to me, it was very obvious.
I said it very strongly and I was criticized.
Really strong people are agreeing with me.
So that's OK.
When it comes to China, the more we learn
about their malfeasance regarding the virus
and what they knew very early on and lied
to them.
Speaker 1: OK, so this is just normal.
Trump, I guess we would call it like Trump.
He goes into xenophobic stuff.
I want to skip ahead because of our limited
time to another part of this interview.
Let's continue to be,
Speaker 2: you know, tens of millions of lives
worldwide.
Mr. President, you mentioned gasoline and
the specific statistics are on Election Day.
It was to 20 a gallon national average, according
to Department of Energy.
Right now, it's 311.
That's a massive move incredibly quickly since
Election Day.
I want to ask you about inflation no more.
Speaker 1: Did you see what they did there,
guys?
Did you see what they did since Election Day?
Really?
Well, who was president November, December
and most of January?
This is how they do it.
OK, big picture.
Presidents have very little influence over
gas prices.
Micro.
Why are we now, including since Election Day?
Because they know that gas prices started
jumping in late summer of twenty twenty under
Trump and they continued increasing under
Trump.
And yes, then then they continued increasing
under Joe Biden.
This is how they take a phenomena that's observable
and they politicize it.
There's very little to politicize actually
about gas prices.
Biden or Trump,
Speaker 2: probably because you did business
in the 1970s, the last time the US saw really
aggressive inflation.
A lot of people, if they're young, have never
operated in that kind of environment in America.
What does this portend for Americans, this
new Biden inflation spike
Speaker 1: with Biden inflation spike?
Speaker 2: Let's listen.
Well, it's going to be ugly when you look
at the cost of a house, just the materials
for a house.
It's up 30 or 40 percent in the last few months,
especially lumber, lumber.
They say you can't even get it.
Perhaps they're closing down all their forests
for environmental reasons.
I disagree.
Virus.
I said let's buy our lumber from ourselves.
So we go to Canada.
And Canada is a very good they are very good
negotiators in Canada.
I did the USMC, which was one of the great
achievements.
NAFTA was so bad.
It was so horrible, the worst trade deal ever.
Speaker 1: All right.
So so again here, there's just so much.
First of all, the differences between us and
MSA and NAFTA are relatively modest.
OK, Trump touting USACA as some miraculous
replacement to NAFTA.
Just we've done we've done deep dives on that
completely false.
This issue of connecting Biden to the increase
in real estate prices and lumber, first of
all, under normal scenarios and during twenty
twenty, Trump bragged housing prices are up.
Trump considered it a badge of honor.
Housing prices are up.
That's the sign of a good.
Market trumps a real estate guy.
Housing prices are up means developers like
Trump make more money.
Now, the same phenomena which, of course,
is a result of down supply lines during the
pandemic, combined with people wanting bigger
spaces so that they can work from home in
perpetuity, have driven up the cost of housing
in some markets and it has made lumber a scarce
resource.
OK, and now Trump is saying, well, that's
bad.
Well, you you were saying that this was good
and it was a sign of how great things were
when you were president.
It's all whatever they need to make of it
at the time.
Speaker 2: And although the deals they made
with China were pretty bad, too, I will tell
you that.
But the worst trade deal ever made and I got
it done.
So we have a great trade deal now, but they
close up for us.
I don't want to take down any trees, so we
end up buying them from other countries.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Trump doing economics, always risky and
it makes no sense.
I want to skip ahead to another part of the
interview just to give us a sampling of everything
that's going on here.
Speaker 2: So it's very interesting what's
happening.
So I greatly respect what some of the governors
are doing in some of the states I think they
can solve the problem may be better than the
federal government.
OK, but regarding the federal response, if
the Republicans do retake the Congress, you're
very much working toward and only twenty two,
if you decide to run again and you win in
twenty twenty four in a potential hypothetical
second Trump term, what can be done to counter
the power of these oligarchs?
Well I think what can be done and very strongly
and when you say oligarchs, it's an interesting
term, but I just say big tech because what
they do is illegal.
But they also silenced what should have been
the biggest blockbuster story of the entire
campaign.
You know, that extremely expensive on the
campaign side.
The fact that the Hunter Biden football story
was completely censored and suppressed by
big tech.
Speaker 1: And this is the big story for them
that wasn't told an incredibly flimsy conspiracy
theory about the son of the Democratic candidate
for president.
That's the big story that they believe was
not told.
Speaker 2: OK, I view that justifies labeling
these operators as oligarchs.
Is that fair?
Well, a lot of things are fair.
Look, we first had Celesio.
That's what we first said, silence zl Enzio.
Speaker 1: But the little varnish with
Speaker 2: Hunter Biden because it was very
bad for the Democrats.
So it was a very bad this guy and we'd bring
it up.
And I have to tell you, The New York Post
was incredible.
What they've done is incredible.
Speaker 1: And it is it is incredible.
That's true.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: The abuse they took, it was you
know, I think it's a great newspaper, actually.
A lot of people are relying on it more and
more to bad.
Yeah.
But they are
Speaker 1: just I mean, a lot of people rely
on Fox News, too.
It's scary.
Speaker 2: An incredible job.
And that in that regard.
But they took tremendous abuse.
But that's when you first hear silence.
They silenced a newspaper.
It's the oldest newspaper in our country,
I believe, and it's a big one.
But they silenced a newspaper in our country
because they were talking about Hunter, Biden
and the Senate.
We held if I weren't involved in the Senate
races, nobody ever says this.
I believe it would be 60 to 40 right now with
the Democrats leading by.
Speaker 1: So this is a very interesting revisionist
history.
I understand that Donald Trump becomes president
of the United States as the head of the Republican
Party.
In twenty eighteen, Republicans lose the House
of Representatives to Democrats in twenty.
Twenty, Republicans lose the Senate to Democrats.
50 50 with Kamala Harris is the tie breaking
vote.
And in twenty twenty Republicans lose the
White House.
They lost everything under Trump.
And Trump is somehow still making himself
the hero of his own fairy tale by saying,
well, listen, many of the seats we held in
the Senate were, thanks to me, this guy was
behind Kelly Lefler and this guy was behind
David Perdue.
And they both lost in their special elections
in on January 5th.
And even though it's abundantly clear that
they lost partially because of his mishandling
of the pandemic, partially because he just
made this party a laughing stock for year
after year after year.
And he has the gall to say thanks to me, it's
only 50 50.
It could be it would have been even worse
if it weren't for me
Speaker 2: 10 instead of 50 50.
And Mitch McConnell lost two seats that he
should have had.
He kept talking about.
We're going to give you six hundred dollars.
They're going to give you two thousand those
who can win a race like that.
He said you will get a penny more to the public.
You won't get a penny more.
They're voting and they're saying two thousand
and he's saying six hundred dollars.
He lost those two Senate seats.
So we have 50 50.
I think you would be 60 40 if I weren't endorsing.
If you look at.
Speaker 1: So there it is.
Thanks to Donald Trump, my friends, Republicans
at least can obstruct things which need 60
votes.
Twenty one minutes on Newsmax of pure profit.
Agenda lies, delusions and complete and utter
meaningless distortions, and Republicans love
it, they love it, and this is what they want
more of in 2022 and this is what they want
more of in twenty, twenty four.
Is it going to happen?
I wish I could say definitely not.
But th